on va en parler avec vous guillaume
grallet bonjour guillaume merci d'être
là c'est d'ailleurs l'objet de tags 24
vous allez revenir sur ce hashtag hocine
qui s'impose donc sur les réseaux
sociaux je le disais un acronyme pour
désigner des techniques de recherche
d'informations à partir de données
ouverte à tous aux sims et open-source
is intelligence vous voulez bien nous en
dire plus oui exactement d'ailleurs si
vous regardez france 24 vous avez
forcément remarqué le travail
extraordinaire un des observateurs qui
vont utiliser cet open source
intelligence pour dénicher recouper
vérifier des informations en réalité cet
open source est intelligente elle va
s'appuyer sur des sources disponibles à
tout un chacun de manière plus ou moins
difficiles les faire mouliner analysés
par des technologies et surtout
s'appuyer par une sur une communauté une
communauté avec laquelle on va partager
des informations ce qui va nous
permettre d'aller très vite vers une
information vérifiée c'est exactement ce
qui est intéressant c'est que ces
données utilisées sont totalement
accessible en fait oui elles sont
accessibles à tout un chacun et est ce
que je trouve intéressant et bien c'est
qu'il ya des organismes comme le center
for information résilience par exemple
qui a créé une carte interactive des
conflits en ukraine cette carte
interactive
eh bien il ya des des contributeurs
amateurs mais également des
contributeurs professionnels comme les
observateurs de france 24 dont on
parlait avant l'ère d'internet en
réalité cette recherche d'informations
elles étaient limités en termes d'accès
il fallait par exemple s'appuyer sur des
vols de reconnaissance et d est
également limitée par exemple à des
espions aujourd'hui c'est accessible à
tout un chacun encore faut-il s'appuyer
bien savoir analyser ces informations il
ya d'autres initiatives que je trouve
intéressante comme celle de bening scat
par exemple bening 4 qui est un
collectif qui est né en 2014 en
angleterre et qui a joué qui a travaillé
à l'identification des personnes qui
étaient derrière l'empoisonnement du
chef de l'opposition russe alexis
nabhani ce cas c'est intéressant c'est
que 24 recommande aux gens de
perfectionner leurs compétences avec des
quiz des jeux comme géo gesser par
exemple on va proposer en réalité 2 de
deviner à travers une simple image de
google street map par exemple de se
retrouver ou on est en observant
pariente les espèces d'arbres leurs
inclinations avec le soleil et
concrètement ça signifie quoi sur le
terrain de la guerre alors on va
vérifier en permanence les dires des
adversaires ça marche dans les deux sens
par exemple lorsque la russie disait
qu'elle n'allait pas envahir l'ukraine
et bien des observateurs auront utilisé
l'hocine pour recouper des vidéos tik
tok sur le mouvement de troupes russes
avec une imagerie satellite et ça a
permis de se rendre compte et bien que
même s'il y avait moins de troupes
russes et un endroit il y avait la
création par exemple deux camps russes à
quelques kilomètres de la frontière et
puisque c'est un accessible à ce point
là ça veut dire dur que tout le monde
peut s'y mettre oui alors on retrouve
des spécialistes en cartographie des
passionnés de radio qui essaye de capter
des fréquences ou encore des férus
d'aviation puisqu'on va traquer les le
mouvement des aéronefs dans le dans le
ciel il ya plusieurs outils assez
intéressant assez amusant comme marine
trafic qui va vous permettre d'avoir en
temps réel une photo d'un navire la
provenance et à destination d'un bateau
on va avoir avec sentinelles des images
satellitaires flight radar le mouvement
des avions on a également des outils
d'imagerie inversée en fait en réalité
on peut observer énormément de choses y
compris des mouvements stratégiques
il faut ceci dit exactement faire un
petit peu attention parce que il faut
faire attention surtout avec qui on
partage les informations parce que ça
peut se retourner contre la personne que
vous voulez protéger je vous propose
d'écouter justement baptiste revers un
des spécialistes de la cybersécurité
on va être en capacité grâce à des
techniques de zine de récupérer la
localisation extrêmement précises de la
vidéo ça peut avoir des conséquences
graves si on poste la vidéo directement
sur les réseaux sociaux parce que
aujourd'hui avec les techniques
actuelles si par exemple le camp adverse
récupère cette localisation il va être
en capacité par exemple de d'envoyer un
drone ou ce type de choses donc il faut
faire extrêmement attention
laws in tu es vraiment un outil
formidable mais comme tous les outils
formidables il comporte aussi des
risques ce qu'ils disent et baptista
robert l'instant il faut faire
extrêmement attention oui on voit une
communauté qui est enthousiaste très
intéressante à suivre ceci dit il faut
faire attention puisque certaines
personnes utilisent les codes de cette
communauté pour diffuser des vidéos de
désinformation sur télégramme en réalité
l'information reste un combat de tous
les jours n'a bien non